[Music]
one more time
can you hear the thing when your lights
off can't talk hit me with a light show
my wind might lose or my draw
haters in love but it come back so if
you really want it in the ring God goes
in the contract off knock his contacts
out you will feel mice trying to take a
Viper ain't no competition in the ring
of Cypher cause I'm spitting phenomenal
swinging fire talking pickled peppers
make them pay the piper cause I might go
live like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a food reduction you'll
be talking like you want a new
concussions and I do the custom attitude
adjustment these are fighting words
better give me that respect that I
deserve for another knuckle sandwich
worry about her egg in bed thinking
Michael Jackson even got his winning
only homie Kevin you a phony homie now
you owe me action have him stinking Tony
Tony Toni Braxton and they all want to
talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant mama got handsome
bread for the tension imma leave them
red you can dance to Redemption
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening
[Music]
as tonight
[Music]
one more time
can you hear the thing when your lights
off can't talk hit me with a light show
my wind might lose or my draw
ers
if you really want it in a ring God
don't send the contract off knock his
contacts out you will feel mice trying
to take a Viper ain't no competition in
the ring of Cypher cause I'm spitting
phenomenal swinging fire talking pickled
peppers make them pay to Piper cause I
might go left like a rude discussion and
deflate your chest like a food reduction
you be talking like you want a new
concussions and I do to custom attitude
adjustment these are fighting words
better give me that respect that I
deserve for another sandwich I would
serve Heaven's tipping moving like a
tire swerve out here acting bad thank
you Michael Jackson even got his winning
only homie Kevin you a phony homie now
you owe me action have em thinking Tony
Toni Toni Braxton and they all want to
talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant mama got handsome
and Bradford attention imma leave them
red you could dance in Redemption
laughs
[Music]
foreign
to another exciting episode of Kos
with King David the professional fan
what's going on people
let me see who we got now
we got ninja squirrel 30 what's going on
Isaac what's good Isaac
everybody hear me good let me know my
levels is good what's good
we in Uncharted Territory today folks we
got um
Bud the bum basher
fighting tonight and I don't
I don't know about this uh
bkl Prime app I don't
I'm having a lot of issues with it right
now and we all know Tio Fimo
Lopez uh on ESPN and top rank that app
is absolutely trash so
Brothers
and sisters I have no idea
what's going to happen right now but we
all tapping in so let's tap in first
what you sipping on
sipping on a little something citrus
you know cut through the you know this
the winter Blues
a little sprite and rake roof
it's
good
a little lemon
hello
Orange
low lime
craziest thing is my wife uh
thinks lemons and limes are the same
thing it's kind of crazy
um like they don't even look the same
absolutely nuts
what's going on
Don what's good
levels on point Thank You Isaac
all right
um
like I said we're in Uncharted Territory
first and foremost
let's keep it a buck
Errol Spence is being chased by
something crazy because this dude has
been in his fourth car accident now the
most publicized car accident was the car
accident that uh with the Ferrari that
flipped over right
and that involved him being inebriated
uh and and he was going upwards of 100 I
guess miles an hour or whatever and
flipped out and uh God grace it was no
other cars involved it was just you know
him and he survived and he's fine
the next car accident he was rear-ended
right and that was um
like a minor fender bender but it still
was offender you know something that you
you can get afraid of right you know
you're still in a traumatic state
this dude
was in
thank God he was in his bulletproof uh
car
and you know anytime something's
bulletproof they have to reinforce it
with heavy steel right so they reinforce
this car with heavy steel and his his
car is Bulletproof
uh young teen 14 years old took his car
as his parents car joy riding or a
stolen car that's unclear at the moment
so allegedly it's his parents car I'm
gonna go with that and this guy hit
aerospin's car head on 14 year old kid
I don't know if the kid is okay I hope
the kid is okay
but man oh man
Spence cars total I like spin said in
his live stream
if he was in his other car that kid
would have ran straight through his car
absolutely something horrifying I don't
know what's chasing this dude I don't
know what's going on with this guy that
uh car accident seemed to plague him in
such the Mana
um but um thank God he's okay thank God
he's all right and Bud the bumbasher you
still got to worry about uh Spence so uh
you know bud is fighting that Venetian
tonight hopefully we can get that fight
hopefully I can call that fight
um I paid for the BLK Prime uh app I
don't know what's going on probably
you're gonna have to reform you my money
because right now all I'm getting is a
blank screen with a little uh like a
loading joint it's not cool we all know
how ESPN does ESPN plays this game up
until like around 10 30 uh quarter two
and then you could probably access the
app happens with me all the time so I'm
cool with that I want to give a shout
out to my son uh Thanksgiving came over
brought us pop some do say so uh give a
shout out to you hope you're watching
and um I'm gonna take a shot today all
right so love my boy he knows uh
he knows how to make an interest came
here with his uh his lovely fiance uh to
the house it was good it was it was a
great Thanksgiving and I and I do
appreciate him for showing up and being
the man that I raised him to be
fantastic to see
let me see what's going on there
Jesus X Crystal what's going on baby
it was bulletproof and it still got
destroyed that's crazy yup
Lopez is a bum
um
Tio Fimo he he's not a bum
the problem is Teo Fimo
believes his own hype you know
um I think his father is great for him
but I think his father is a problem for
him too right so sometimes you got to
tell your kids exactly how it is but he
understands how fragile his kid's psyche
is so I don't think he uh tries to give
him too much honesty and that can be a
huge problem because if you don't be
real with your children
um they're going to go around here
looking crazy when he when they put a
microphone in his face so you know he
says off the cuff stuff he says a lot of
weird things and the weird things is uh
is because he's being
aided if you will he's in being enabled
you know and I don't think he needs a
bunch of yes men around him so Tia
female if you can get some dudes around
you that can give you the real real um I
think you can be the star that you're
gonna be but you're in the wrong weight
Division I think right now tonight I
think Martin has a hell of a shot
because remember teofimo is supposed to
fight Pedraza
they switched this over and now you got
Martin in there and Martin is a late
replays
Martin has the ability to upset tiafimo
if he can box teal Fimo shoot some right
hands he can actually beat him so this
is probably the most dangerous fight for
Teo female I say the same thing to Bud
remember Buster Douglas happened right
before Evander Holyfield and Mike Tyson
was supposed to have a fight
Mike Tyson wanted to go to Japan and get
some quick money
with Buster Douglas
that fight should have happened
it didn't happen
and then Buster Douglas wound up beating
the brakes off of Mike Tyson
and then Mike Tyson uh had to sit on the
sidelines and heal up and get stuff
right while Evander Holyfield knocked
out Buster Douglas with one swift punch
so I say it is to say a lot of times you
think you're ahead of the game and
you're too smart sometimes you out slick
yourself but the bum Basher and you will
always be no see I'm not gonna call you
bud the duck
because you did Ducks Pence but
hopefully you know when Spence comes
back around and you you can see that you
know Spencer's in his car accident I
could have lost that bread
you know let me get this fight now
or
you can keep running right because your
your whole history your whole
uh fight history for bud
a lot of has been
a lot of dudes out of weight classes a
lot of glass chin dudes a lot of dudes
on their way out the door
you know I hate when people say that he
fought the best version of Sean Porter
he did not fight the best version of
Sean Porter Sean Porter had two bad hips
one that was on the way out and one was
gone
and if you know Sean Porter Sean Porter
sits low so that he must have been in
agony that whole fight or whatever but
his father knew that he was out that's
why the towel came in and stuff like
that but
but the bomb Basha
and he's fighting evanesian tonight
if avynesian upsets butt watch this part
to happen avionisian is going to go
straight and fight Spence
because the the PBC is going to offer
avenuesian
a great amount of money
and advanesian will definitely lose to
Spence and Spence will definitely take
that belt and become unified and then
you know vacate and leave butt you know
to fight nobody so I always say take
what you got when you get it when it's
there when it presents itself always
step up to Greatness when you can don't
put it off tomorrow what you can do
today
because tomorrow may never come for you
so again respect
to and and I mean God man you dodged a
huge bullet Spence
get all your cars to be Bulletproof
let me see what's going on guys let me
see
Mac what's going on baby
yes Tia female fights down to this
competition he got cocky before that
cambosa's fight and tried to get him out
of there in the first round and he got
caught by that right hand remember when
cam Bose was caught him with that right
hand put him on his butt his confidence
left out the building right then and
cam Bose's confidence went straight
through the roof I mean he he could he
he called camposis I guess it was in the
ninth round at the tenth round again
but Cannon boss is held on and he just
pushed through like a true champion is
supposed to push through and he decided
that he wasn't going to leave and that
uh teofimo had to kill him
and cambosis came and got what he wanted
the problem with that is
that teofimo could have fought camposis
again
why didn't he
why did Devin Haney have to go all the
way to Australia
to beat cam bosses not once but twice
because guarantee you
to your female had a rematch clause with
camboses
he didn't initiate his rematch clause I
guess he was talking about he had to
make weight and stuff like that did you
see how comfortable that teal Fimo made
weight this time right here because
while on the scale he takes a Willy
Wonka chocolate bar and takes a bite
he was so comfortable enough that he can
do that they'll let you know that he
made this weight very comfortable it
wasn't a sacrifice really to make this
way
he looks in phenomenal shape he looks
cut up like he's never looked cut up
before
he looks fantastic I mean I really hope
Tia female takes this guy very seriously
because Pedraza was a threat Martins are
even dangerous threat uh
to Tia female
let me go on
yeah man listen I'm always going to talk
facts about these boxing dudes you know
uh I thought Bud record is is padded
like a lot of top ranked Fighters
records are padded right
and then he comes up to the 147 division
the welterweight division
and he fights his best friend
you know um Porter Porter's his was his
friend guys the next day he's on his
podcast I mean look look at what you're
seeing and understand what you're seeing
right call a spade a spade I'm not
saying he's not a great fighter I did a
video before with saying that bud is a
savant but he's he's probably one of the
best Switch Hitters and when I say
Switch Hitters um
that means that he can go Orthodox in
Southpaw that means he can fight with
either hand he can go with either Lead
Foot and he can switch on a dime I'm
saying that he's one of the best since
Marvin Hagler
he doesn't have a chin like Marvin
Hagler
when you can be rocked by lighter
weights and and
I just
I don't think that he he'll be able to
stand up to the pressure and I think his
Camp knows that he won't be able to
stand up to the pressure of Spence
and I don't think he's confident enough
in a rematch
you know because he has high aspirations
he says this out his mouth that he has
high aspirations but a person with high
aspirations understands and knows that
in this fight game
tomorrow's not promised right one punch
can actually end everything so what you
want to do is put all your ducks in a
row if you have these ducks in a row
Undisputed is standing right in front of
you you beat Spence for Undisputed and
you go fight Jamelle
for Undisputed at uh 154 because Jamal
is Undisputed so you have a direct path
boom bow so you came from 135 Undisputed
I mean 148 Undisputed went to 147 if you
beat Spence you Undisputed then you go
to 154 out Undisputed you'll probably be
the greatest champion who ever lived
and a four belt era
if he doesn't take it and he doesn't
take that path
why the hell is he fighting evanesian
that's when you are too high on your own
Supply man
let me see what's going on yo um
because you from restream and it says
Facebook user I really want you to join
the YouTube you know jump off of
Facebook jump onto YouTube so I can see
exactly who you are because you gave a
good comment and you're giving real good
comments TC fighting tonight yeah didn't
even realize that Manny Pacquiao's
fighting tonight well actually tomorrow
the way the time difference is is weird
so Manny Pacquiao was fighting but he's
fighting the exhibition Manny Pacquiao
said he wants to fight but Manny
Pacquiao said he wants to fight Spence
I would rather see Spence fight Pacquiao
I'll be honest with you I really want to
see that because I was cheated out of
that when Spence had the eye problem and
you know
we all know what happened after that let
me see okay
reporter wasn't in the book yes that's
right no excuses we all know what's up
however he wasn't supposed to say that's
what that's what's up what do you think
about Haney versus Loma or Stevenson
Loma is making a lot of excuses for
Haney
have you noticed that oh Haney's so big
um paintings like a heavyweight
Loma wasn't making these excuses before
when Devin Haney oh he was young he went
behind the ears he didn't do anything
but when he went and beat the dude who
beat you
and he beat that dude handily two times
cambos has got that work second time he
got that work work
Loma is like oh I need a fight to you
know to get warmed up since when you
heard Loma say that
I think David Haney keeps alone at a
distance I think Devin Haney pot shots
Loma see the problem is
Loma has the the best feat I've seen in
a fighter
the best feat I mean except for Sugar
Ray Robinson I mean let's keep it a buck
Sugar Ray Robinson has probably the he's
he's God in in in in in in human form in
a boxing ring period
that's pound for pound he's pound for
pound that means when if you could put
him at any weight class that guy would
dominate in a fashion that is unheard of
that's Sugar Ray Robinson loma's feet
is the best the way he moves around the
ring he darts in he darts out he judges
this and so great his shoulder movements
everything is great about him his
hand-eye coordination is fantastic
but he's a small guy
Devin Haney is a young
bigger
I'm not saying stronger because he slaps
with his punches he hasn't been able to
sit down on his punches
and that's okay
he knows how to to win right so and he
has a level-headed pops that's in his
Corner that tells him when he's too high
on his own Supply when he needs to be a
little grounded
so we're seeing that you know um with
Devin Haney Devin Haney knows that he's
going to go and do this
um so I think Devin Haney beats Loma I
think he beats him by a split decision
though because I think in the middle
round Loma starts to take control after
probably because Loma is a slow starter
so you say after the sixth round Loma is
going to start working in there you say
from the sixth to the ninth round it'll
probably be Loma time and then from
there Devin Haney must turn it up he
must show his Youth and he must show his
strength from us push Loma back he must
use the jab must use the right hand he
must make Loma respect him
Stevenson
and Devin Haney that's a great fight
will that fight happen
will Shakur Stevenson be locked up
allegedly he was at a dice game
where a million a millionaire
you know a superstar from you know the
Migos
was
um
assassinated
and he's there
now I don't know not casting any
aspersions probably I am right
be talking about it
that guy better get some fights in now
I've seen the best of them
be on the custody doing something and be
caught up in the streets and
you don't get those fights so
um Stevenson versus uh Devin Haney I
think Stevenson has more sharp power
than uh Devin Haney but I think Devin
Haney has a better work rate uh than
Stevenson Stevenson boards me a lot with
his movements he has the look
he has the aggression when it's time but
he doesn't
have the excitement behind him I think
Devin Haney has a little bit more
excitement because I think it really is
pops be honest with you because pops
pushes him and pushes them in different
directions yeah loma's old
okay let me see uh what about if Bud
goes up to uh one up to
145 what do you mean yeah 154.
but but gets destroyed at 154 Bud
doesn't have a chin
you know we we keep thinking that bud
has this chin bun doesn't have a chin if
he fights Jamel Jamel is a killer and
now you talk about Jamal Jamal's a
Savage but uh Jamel is a killer
he fights Jamel Jamel has all the belts
what is he gonna do who is he going to
fight up there he's gonna go to 154 and
get destroyed by those heavy dudes those
dudes is Big you know um butt is a small
guy and he knows he's a small guy really
honest with you
but it's supposed to be uh fighting at
um
probably 140. you say 140 was the best
way he can fight tank Davis and those
dudes like that he can fight uh Ryan
Garcia
you know I would love to see Ryan Garcia
versus Bud
I would love to see the battle of the
suspect chins
because I think Ryan Garcia has speed
that can catch butt and I think that
left hook off of Ryan Garcia is
something Savage
I think Bud won't see that left foot
coming
but see then you have Bud with his right
hand he'll switch up on him and he can
stay close to him so
it's different things in that fight I
would love to see Ryan Garcia versus Bud
I think that's a fight I would die to
see like that that's a fight that I can
see
all right let me see what's going on
here
Pacquiao's sweet to the gut like Fox
chocolate yeah suspense would destroy
them facts Loma got excuses that's right
100 Charlie might kill but yeah for sure
Tony Harrison would give Bud a tough
time
let me tell you something
Tony Harrison will beat the hell out of
butt
y'all remember Tony Harrison is the same
dude that fought Jamel
Charlo
beat him the first time
Tony Harrison is not a joke he's not a
game
do you see what type of person that
Jamelle had to turn into to beat Tony
Harrison
so that means they were equally on par
in any given night they can flip-flop
like one night it'd be this guy's night
or one night it'd be that guy's night
Tony Harrison is not a bum
he talks a lot he may irritate you
but would never fight Tony Harrison
never never in a million years
castilio's too strong will walk butt
down Bud would switch and turn remember
bud is not a big guy if y'all got to
look at the sizes of these men Bud came
from a very light weight all the way up
so you gotta look at like Bud's frame
you know then look at Bud's competition
you you gotta see who he fought to get
to where he is and and
why he's who he is
remember ESPN
top rank
can grab the media and make the media
believe certain things they work very
well with top rank right
Barbarian is famous for building people
up
and then when they when they have to go
and have to go over and fight PBC
Fighters or they have to go and fight
the Zone Fighters
doesn't really work out well for these
dudes right Bob arum lost a lot of
fights to Don King
so Bob Aaron likes to keep his stuff
in-house so you see his in-house fight
is fighting each other I mean a lot of
these news like to do in-house stuff
because it keeps the money home but Bob
is a master at this thing and I think he
did butted disservice by not having Bud
fight more stiffer competition but in
his stable he gave him what he was able
to handle let me see
what's going on Lord Supremacy
yo listen Tony was winning until he got
clipped
excuse me
well I
um
can I say Tony was winning I think Tony
was
how can I say
um it was probably there's probably even
or close on the scorecards right because
remember Tony got clipped in the first
fight
this dude just couldn't get him
and and Tony got away and I think um
that was a quick stoppage
for Tony in the second fight I mean Tony
was out on his feet but I still think it
was a quick stoppage I think Tony was
able to go a little bit more especially
if you're the champion and you're
defending I mean until he falls out and
he's dead on the floor nah he gotta let
that go bro you can't you can't um be a
referee and stop that you got to let
that go so
I mean I didn't agree with it at the
time
um I still don't agree with it now I
think that um Tony Harrison
deserves excuse me a third fight
and quite possibly he might get it
see that's what I'm talking about about
this app
I'm refreshing this app pushing this app
and um
it's BLK Prime is crap
same thing with the
right now I'm watching
all my UFC stuff
right now
um what I have right now
Mitchell versus uh tapora
on UFC
and don't get me to call UFC because you
don't have me telling you uh they got a
butt naked choke so don't do that don't
do that give me my fights
Apollo what's going on baby
that's right
neck watch what's going on baby
what you said you yo you stuck in the
Zoo parking lot from taking your little
brother to the zoo lights it looks like
the whole city is there
yo
see Yo think about it this way
budford American
when Amir Khan
was what done
cooked baked after he didn't had how
many concussions after his reflex has
done slowed up so
I mean it's not wrong it's something on
the Belt man you go get that old
Champion if you walk into the street you
go get them
the same way Spencer's gonna run down on
Pacquiao you go get him you go get him
I'm not saying that you don't pick
low-hanging fruit you pick that
low-hanging fruit because you need those
names in order to build your names
because remember they come with a fan
base
so he goes in there he beats him
and um
it's
he beats him in a manner that makes his
fan base say who's this guy
this is the guy that beat the guy I like
so this guy gots to be good right so he
goes over there and and then you follow
that guy that's how fan base stealing
happens
that's how cross-pollination happens
you're still going to be a fan
of Amir Khan but if this is his last
fight and this guy beats him you're
going to be more inclined to watch but
after right so this is that's what you
do old Champions pass the Baton on to
the next guy Canelo did it with uh what
is the Shane Mosley he did it with a a
prefla Fighters you know um I really
thought Canelo had the best decision
making beating older champions
and being beating name recognized dudes
not this later half of his career later
half of canelo's career
he started fighting just European dudes
and staying away from the American base
Fighters not saying that you know David
benavidez who is Mexican but you know he
fights out of the U.S
um these guys are dangerous Jamal Charlo
is dangerous you know um bubu andrades
is dangerous he stayed away from those
guys
and
when you when you're trying to be great
you have to fight your contemporaries
you don't go say oh I'm the money man
y'all gonna make money
and then come back and get me now that's
that's not how it goes
you are supposed to fight your
contemporaries who would Ali be without
Ken Norton without any Shavers you know
without he even fought Larry Holmes when
he wasn't supposed to when that was your
sparring partner
you know what Joe Frazier George Foreman
Muhammad Ali went out and fought his
contemporaries his the people that's
across the ring that they say is the
best that's in your division you go do
that Roy Jones went and got got that
done he went and sought out James Tony
he went and sought out Bernard Hopkins
I don't care what you say about Oscar De
La Hoya he did the same thing he went
and sought anybody that they said that
was that dude Oscar De La Hoya went
there win lose a drawer
he went there so these guys got to get
up off that Floyd Mayweather I gotta
hold my o cause it can't go crap
you got to get in there and fight your
contemporaries you got to stop being a
sucker
these dudes are suckers
when you see what's going on
that's right game boom see you next year
at E3 baby
that's right De La Hoya
see when Floyd for De La Hoya
De La Hoya was the a side this is where
that a-side stuff comes from De La Hoya
was the a side De La Hoya had all the
concessions De La Hoya got the ring size
Dale or you got the gloves De La Hoya
got to pick everything you know what day
like oh you got paid the most money you
know what Floyd did
I'm going to go beat him up
I'm going to go win
and then I'ma turn that win into
something different
and that's where the hateful Floyd
started right that's when he was pretty
boy right it's pretty boy I think he was
pretty boy for like one more fight after
that and then he became money make
you got to look at the timeline on that
he was pretty boy for that little bit
and then he turned into money May and
money maze when he understood how to to
turn that viewership and that hate Into
Cash
so
I'm watching uh Mitchell and tapora from
UFC then round two
um
tempura is on top of mitchu right now
and he's uh
he's doing a crossover he got him up
against the gate don't even get me to
try to call UFC be honest with you guys
I'm just I'm rude with it
let me see what's going on
tank Davis card next week is gonna be
crazy and I won't have a problem with
Showtime Showtime never has a problem
you know ESPN man ESPN is hot trash and
this BLK Prime op to see that's the
reason why I ain't put uh bud but the
bum basher on um
right here on the on the face card uh
when I when I tweeted it out because I
don't know
about this BLK Prime you know a lot of
times when these guys do these apps
Floyd did some weirdo app and I had to
refund my money
so
I forgot what app that was it was some
weird old app and I'm like this guy here
they they listen to all these uh
these slick talking dudes and to put
theyself on these apps
and it is what it is let me see
all right so temporia's surprise uh
submits uh
he submitted this dude
well this guy was bleeding all over the
place oh my God decided to say I would
have submit it too whole side of his
head leaking
oh my God absolutely crazy well you know
what
let me open this up
you know like I said
shout out to my son
you know I love you
do say
that's it
you say strong
one shot to you and everything that you
do I love you boo
I'm dare God
rough stuff man rough stuff
yeah you know what I should have put a
splash or something in it but I I don't
really be drinking
I do say like that because it's rough
boy rough on you just take a light
that's it for tonight
and not at all not at all
um
you know what that's what real men do
not questioning his manhood because he's
a fighter anybody that's up in that ring
is a man man woman whatever right you
step in that ring you're a champion
inside yourself
is the choices that you make to get to
where you at the choices
that you make Define who you are the
same way the choices in the ring
Define exactly who you are
right
you get hit by their right hand
you have a choice to stand your ground
pivot roll and punch back
you have a choice to catch and Pitch you
have a choice to fold down you have you
have all the choices in the world
so his choices in the moment that Define
the champion right so are you gonna sign
that contract
are you gonna let a million dollars
standing away from you becoming exactly
who you are because if everybody thought
like that Floyd would not be who he is
Floyd took the short end of the stick he
took the short end of the stick in the
promotion he came out second he took the
short end of the stick all the way
around the boards with Oscar De La Hoya
because what he had to do was go out and
beat the man who is the man to become
the man he did that
and every Champion knows that
you're not going to get concessions in
the beginning but you're coming with one
belt to somebody who has three belts who
did the heavy lifting you came in you
you fought Jeff Horn bro
Jeff Horn
and don't tell me Jeff Hornby Pacquiao
because he didn't that was a job
they job Pacquiao
I don't even think you beat Pacquiao
back when Jeff Horn beat Pacquiao
I don't think Jeff I don't think
Pacquiao took him serious
but that's on Pacquiao
I digress
you come in with the wbl dude nothing
else you didn't fight nobody didn't
fight anybody no Danny Garcia no Keith
Thurman nobody
you fought Sean Porter your homeboy
that's like me and Saul fighting and
solve is gonna retire
you get it
so you're going up against the champion
the man
put your head down
take a little hit take a little less
head take a little less Dead come out
second who cares a nobody cares
and beat the brakes off them unless you
don't think you can
I don't know
I guess you heard the stories
Spence break bones baby he breaks men he
breaks them
absolutely nuts
I'm watching UFC right now and I'm gonna
be watching boxing
he said you got 20 on solved
yeah I don't
um
I don't really mess with Henny like that
honey have people fighting in the middle
of the street I don't do that man
I don't do that
I'm more of a tequila guy tequila you
relax you know
a little siesta sleepy time
actually tequila is a whole lot better
for you to be honest with you too
especially if you get it in
um a good brand
foreign
do you understand how true that is
people want to be money made but forget
about Pretty Boy Floyd Pretty Boy Floyd
did the grind Pretty Boy Floyd for
everybody Under the Sun that was in his
circumference Pretty Boy Floyd was
probably the nicest most dangerous
brittle hand dude that you knew every
day he had to soak his hand he had to
wrap his hands his hands wasn't the best
hands in the world
and that I think that was a detriment to
Floyd because a lot of times
Floyd wanted to be that KO artist and he
had to turn into who he was because of
his Affliction with his hands you know
um
that sucks you know everybody walks in
there nobody walks in the ring 100 I
have never heard of somebody say yo
really honestly I mean they tell you
that in the beginning because of the
pay-per-view numbers but you know uh
yeah I did have a bad toe or I did have
a this or I did have that you know um
I've never heard nobody ever walk into
the ring 100 it's always something that
they gotta you know walk through or work
through
so it is what it is
but um true Champions work through
everything
let me see
you think you think you oh you've never
seen me fight oh and you think I'm slow
see like in a in a in a wrestling match
solver beat me in the wrestling imagine
we're gonna be on the floor wrestling
solve is an A1 wrestler
I'm a fighter
you don't think I know how to cut off
the ring
last not even a minute
I just cut the ring off
keep them right there
and when you're in shooting distance
I'ma shoot
the gun the right hand finishing
but come on man
that's I gave you for instance but
wrestling hell no that guy's a Savage
uh absolute Savage he'll just grab you
you'll be talking about here grab you
get you around your neck you finish UFC
pull you up boy stay away from Salt
yeah and you know what it is y'all think
y'all think y'all think
we are all the same guy
we're all the same guy just in different
bodies right
keep sleeping on attic
oh people finally saw exactly how big
attic is
adding a big boy
you're finally so who he is right big
boy
all right so and y'all see [ __ ]
stocky blocky
and he liked that karate stuff be done
chop you in your throat make your
windpipe disappear
um nah Four Horsemen Is For Real it's a
four horsemen thing for real man
something dangerous
yeah 1-800 tequila yeah with a splash of
pineapple on the Rocks baby you telling
the truth
I mean yeah I'm gonna give you that
because definitely that's the truth
the fatality
hell yeah
and he said Atticus Bam Bam Bigelow yo
yo remember Bigelow
with the fire on his head
remember that dude yo I love Bam Bam
Bigelow
dear God this is not gonna be yo yo
yo I swear to God I'll probably never
call that's why I didn't call
um that Tyson Fury crap
uh last week
I know a lot of times y'all be like yo
why does he always call you know PVC
fights because PVC fights never give me
a problem never
you know top ranked fights give me a
problem
um I don't know I don't know what this
uh BLK Prime stuff is I really I can't I
can't lie to you and tell you I know
what this BLK Prime crap is
um I think Bud made a very bad mistake
with this uh app
so
you know um I'ma give it to 11.
I'm gonna give it to 11 and everything
should kick in
you know but on God and them man might
be a soccer night but I'm looking at I'm
looking at UFC's uh take down of these
dudes I can tell you this I can get the
Manny Pacquiao fight with no problem
because it's overseas all you got to do
is just tune in to overseas TV and it's
um the same thing with Floyd when Floyd
was fighting in Dubai and he was doing
the exhibition
those those those are nothing because
those are like direct stream from
something that they do over there so all
you have to do is like pay uh use your
VPN and pay for uh they their Channel
over there easy whatever and whatever
bucks that they use over there
that's right sometimes you gotta let it
go yo okay um what movies I'm looking
forward to next year I'm definitely
hopefully if The Flash movie does come
out after all that stuff that I did see
uh with James Gunn
um
very disconcerting the whole DC Universe
is being rebooted and everybody is going
to probably be recast that's huh
you know I'm looking forward to the
Joker movie
um I don't know if that's coming next
year definitely looking forward to Mario
that Super Mario movie I have problems
with certain things because they always
showing Mario in every trailer that I
see like Mario's a sucker
right where's the Super part right he's
like just Mario
I'm not super so
um I'm looking forward to that and it
looks very very good to me
um
I just want him to be super I want him
to be because Bowser is the most
intimidating Force if you saw the
trailer
you know when he went to the frost
Kingdom
you know and and laid waste to the
Penguins so you know Mario just I don't
know man it's I just want him to become
super I want to see I don't want to see
him you know put Fair he he got beat up
by Donkey Kong like in the first fight
that was like I was just like come on
man like in Luigi you know we all know
Luigi soft so I don't know I just want
to see the movie and I hope it's not a
long build when he becomes to do this
hitting the platforms and doing all that
stuff you know because remember Sonic
was the man from from the beginning like
from the beginning of the film even as a
child so
um
I don't know I think I just hope they
have a different approach to it right
now I'm watching Sandman on Netflix
uh the wife and I felt like this it was
crazy
so Sandman on the Netflix is crazy so
remember r r Tuesdays at 5 p.m uh attic
and I
definitely get into it oh my God it's so
much stuff happening on Tuesday got a
lot of stuff happened in this Tuesday I
just thought about that
just thought about that I hope I don't
whose show I got to be on oh those guys
got away too
yeah they cancel Blue Beetle Aquaman the
castle
Blue Beetle Indiana Jones Guardians of
Galaxy 3 yes of course
I don't even know what that is
okay I gotta block you
yeah you gone
yeah they cancel Blue Beetle
man a Super Smash Brothers movie I think
they're gonna have a lot of those
elements here because they already
showed Mario Kart I don't know man
highly possible highly possible stuff
I hope it's good
no he's not gonna bring back the council
Michael uh Keaton Batman
this guy James Gunn see this is the
problem with getting new regime change
they want to make their own footprint
they want to make their own legacy their
own name
so
he's not going to mess with the Joker
movie
right and he's not going to make mess
with uh Robert Patterson's Batman movie
right he's going to do these two movies
in alternate universes they like
elsewhere
uh movies
so those movies are secure and safe
those lineages are safe he's talking
about the main continuity
Ezra Miller really messed up a lot of
things with his ongoing alleged
felonious Behavior
all right uh Henry Cavill
and that Superman movie not being a draw
enough to do a Superman 2
um Ben Affleck's Batman not being
athletic enough uh
is these things
gal gadot's Wonder Woman the second one
I thought there was a bad direction that
they took the movie in and it led to
them throwing away the third script
right I thought Black Adam was really
good but
it didn't make it didn't translate to
dollars
so James Gunn is looking at all of this
remember James Gunn is highly successful
and critically acclaimed from guardians
of galaxy one two and three looks to
follow the trend so if three is
critically acclaimed they're not going
to tell him no and what he wants to do
so when he recast people and he redoes
these movies and he starts these movies
all from scratch and then he puts the
James Gunn uh thumbprint on it
that's what we're gonna get so just
let's hope for the best right hopefully
this is a step in the right direction
hopefully they do World building
they don't do the same oh we're going to
tell the story of Superman flying the
Earth and all that I thought the man who
still did a fantastic job in doing that
I thought we saw Krypton in his best
light I thought we saw Superman in a
different light I just didn't think that
uh Henry Cavill fit Superman because of
his stature and his size that's the only
thing I thought uh
oh what is it Brandon roof the one
before that from Superman Returns I
thought he was the best Superman because
of uh you know
how I view Superman I think Superman has
a swimmers body let me see um
I really wanted to see Snyder and
Justice movie
yeah
they just have a problem with Snyder I
think Snyder wants a lot of control and
I don't think uh Warner Brother wants to
give Snyder the level of control he
needs to make a universe in his fashion
but Snyder universe is and the way he
views Heroes is very dark and very
disconcerning so
um
if you want that type of universe
then you put up with Snyder if you don't
and you want something more Marvel more
grounded uh more lighthearted and more
comicky then you have to go in another
Direction so I think they go in another
Direction just because
Snyder's worlds is too dark you know
it's just it is what it is
listen guys
foreign
this app ain't working right we got 12
minutes to get right
and
This is BS as anybody else is anybody
else App working for top rank
because top ranks it said that it was
supposed to go live at 9 30.
it hasn't went live yet so please let me
know if any if your app went live
said Batman
Batman will be a good building point
Batman is overused
man is overused I think I think they
always go to Batman to save them and I
think
I think green Latin should be a good
starting point
right
um I think
Green Lantern
should be a good starting point
and then go to ground base Heroes right
go to
I'm saying no
let me see
it should be it should be now I just got
a notification
I restart the app I don't know what the
hell that is about
let us see new
at restart
click in Click out
let us see
this is absolutely ridiculous
this is nuts is
it's
horrible
and UFC doing anything I guess because
you will see doing anything I don't know
this is bum
absolutely bummedness
well it was bound to happen one day
when you're depending on stuff tell me
if you got apps running
Constantine yes Black Canary you're
watching it on ESPN right
what is going on with my ESPN
see ESPN right now I got the UFC
and I just can't switch it over to the
box and I'm trying
they had the best card too man that ESPN
had probably the best card
foreign
okay so let me see
Justice League was alternating yes
that's what I'm talking about
he said I got the real plug on that
cable homie you need to hook me up
because um
ESPN don't like me unless I double up on
payments or something I don't know what
it is I'm watching ESPN right now but I
got UFC
the ESPN apps do suck
it's running slow for you right
they said actually uh Batman out there
duking it out with razakula Vandal
Savage yeah
I'm not gonna lie this UFC fight right
now is crazy
I am not gonna lie right now you got
duplicitous versus till
and then duplexes is on this on the back
on his back tails on top of him he'll
know where the ground a pound until his
hammer and smashing them in the face
and uh
it's going to a crossover duplicities is
got standing up and he drops still this
is crazy it's actually a good fight
it's just hard for me to call
excuse me
yes it sucks man
let me see
big baby Anderson fight is about to
start mad as hell man
it's the hell is going
hold on
let me close out this app
okay
start everything from the Baseline
I said King go to sleep
this is a dub
absolute dope
this is a dump this is
hold on
let me put in a dispute right now
yeah okay
yeah Terence Crawford versus Dave gonna
have Venetian
until FEMA Lopez versus Martin
I got an email from BLK Prime and said
please be with bear with us
I give
what time is it
got five more minutes I'm a man of my
word I'ma stick to it I'm a man of my
word
we'll rock out this uh Whatchamacallit
but um nope
what we got going on there the Grinch
let me see
you watching it on regular ESPN right
you see it won't actually start it's
just rotating and doing this right the
same exact thing this is what I'm
telling you I go right back to it and
it's and it shows that it shows the
screen
and it just is loaded then I back out
and then I go to the ESPN I see I'm at
ESPN plus right
ESPN plus is giving me the UFC fight
regular ESPN I'm getting that loading
Circle
BLK will Prime is a watch it's just a a
like a um it's a sellout just like a
triangle with a slash in it I don't even
know what the hell that is
how the hell I'm watching the UFC
but not watching the fight
absolutely nuts
absolutely nuts I damn sure won't have
this problem with tank Davis next week I
can tell you that I know that for a fact
I know that for a fact
and I'ma keep trying but
see it says uh
error code
and I gotta dispute it
stupidness man
life is what you're making
could do the UFC till and do blisses but
I don't want to do the UFC
gotta do like what
who's winning the fight oh and the UFC
I logged into my TV provider's website
and went to the regular channel see
that's right
yo you said
you're not so legal streaming well you
need to send me that link because my
legal stream ain't working right it's
giving me the fight
ESPN Plus
the hell is the Plus
that's right
Frank Martin fight
that's right
oh yeah uh Davis is no no Davis is the
17th isn't it
he they switched it to oh it was yeah it
was two weeks apart from about two weeks
apart from but
it was two weeks apart from but yeah
that's that's that's crazy
this is man I am
I apologize
I would I would uh
I would put on the fight my damn self
I know but I knew bug was gonna do this
man
and I don't really care too much about
but I think I I think that was I don't
know what that thing is
I guess he'll figure it out tomorrow but
the Teo Fimo thing until I can figure
this out all I'm getting see because I
have ESPN plus and with the plus it just
keeps giving me the UFC and I'm leaning
up I'm clicking the button for the
boxing
see ESPN plus live is
I'm clicking for the boxing but I keep
getting that Circle and it's not loaded
in
and I left it there for a minute
oh yeah the Zone ripped you off yeah
man I'm not watching but on no tape
delay
bug can go to hell
bugging go to hell like who the hell
wants to hear about it after the fact
after the world knows what happened
nobody not a soul not not a soul so what
you what are you doing you're doing fake
closed circuit television
not a soul wants to see that not a
living soul
it's 11 o'clock dudes
dudes and dudettes
the King has taken well you know what
this is the last round
fatal and um
duplicitous and I'm just gonna watch
this last round here
because um
they're actually giving you
everything that they need
so you got to tell at uh sticking out
his jab hand at duplicities
and um
duplicities is oh no till is uh southpaw
but they they switch all the time
I guess they're just Strikers huh
I guess it's it's a format for them
but they doing stand-up the place uh
Till's eye is closed his uh right eye is
basically closed
and they don't understand up in the
center to the ring right now so
duplicities keeps switching from
Southport to Orthodox trying to land the
overhand right or overhand left uh till
just hit uh duplicities with uh right
hand
as he's uh
left hand as he's jabbing him
sent to the ring again
and uh duplicities hits uh till with a
left overhand
while till I is crazy
oh nice overhand right from duplicity's
nice jab from duplicities till ahead is
going back
all right
he tried a low kick
but uh tail grab just like
I don't know it's not enough action for
me I mean they they do have some action
you know uh in UFC fights but it's not
enough action for me I mean the older
dudes you know used to you know really
get at it so uh not enough action for me
foreign
you know what yeah I'm gonna try a
different browser
put you in Chrome
you know
I had a feeling today too I was just
like
because my wife was like uh so who's
fighting I said Tio female
that's the one that looks like your
grandson
tfu looks like Liam
I'll show you guys a little picture of
Liam right now
Tio Fimo looks just like this dude had
to ask her daughter
you didn't see this dude did you
[Music]
watch it you're gonna be like this is
ridiculous
look at this little cutie face
it's like a little elf that like they
dropped a little elf Off in our room
you look like a little teal female I'll
be like yo you look like teal Fimo
you're going through Hulu Plus
now I didn't play the Undisputed beta
look whack to me
it looks slow it looks sluggish it looks
whack to me it looks like a very
um very early build of fight night if
you're not gonna come fight night I
better get out of here
and be honest with you I'm be real with
you the the punches aren't stiff enough
pause
you know um I thought that uh
it just it doesn't have the impact
and it gives you fake impact like when
you uh do a punch but the punch doesn't
look like it lands properly I don't know
the Collision detection is is it looks
weird it looks off something's just not
right about it the fighters look good
the outside look good but does it ask
you this question does it look like
better than 360's uh of uh Fight Night
Fight Night Champions does it look
better than the first time that you saw
a fight night no the deformation in the
punches in the face like when when you
punch Roy remember they had Roy versus
Bernard or something like that and you
hit him in the face and his mouth
twisted and he's like oh
you don't see none of that
right okay so you mean to tell me this
current gin
can't beat
a 360 game
then you need to program better
you need to go get every last person
that worked on that fight night and you
need to hire them and help you make a
better game
it doesn't even look better than some of
these UFC uh wrestling games fighting
games
he was being real with you
man
well
I'm doing it one more time resetting it
yo did you say who said that it's on
tape delay
for bud
because I got another BLK Prime email
foreign
[Music]
nothing
but I bet you I got UFC
Petra I got UFC
Oh Long behold UFC
well guys
imma call it
I'm not gonna do like uh Chris did uh
on his uh acceptance speech for God of
War
talking for two hours
and nobody wanted to hear you bro
and who the hell did his makeup he
looked like he had a funeral parlor
makeup on that guy looked crazy
he looked crazy he looked like a crazy
crotos look like he strong armed his way
into the job
out of control
but guys
let me give you out of the intro on that
outro
let's make it happen
good night y'all
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
because I'm spitting Venom a swing of
fire talking pickled peppers make them
pay the piper cause I might go live like
a rude discussion and deflate your chest
like a full reduction you be talking
like you want a new concussions and a
dude a custom attitude adjustment these
are fighting words better give me that
respect that I deserve for another
Redemption
[Music]
foreign
[Music]